the richness of the myths and legends in
A Song of Ice and Fire
is one of the many things that our
tributes to its greatness in this
episode of ideas of Ice and Fire cast we
explore the legend of the ninth king and
queen who ruled over the Nightfort for
13 years performing unspeakable acts of
black magic until they were taken down
by the king in the north and the
king-beyond-the-wall if you want to
watch any of the previous episodes of
this podcast check out the playlist on
my channel titled ideas of Ice and Fire
cast and you can always follow ideas of
Ice and Fire
on Twitter and if you really like this
channel consider supporting it on
patreon now we first hear about the
night King in a Storm of Swords when
bran is at the Nightfort with Meera and
Jojen and Hodor bran can't help but
think of all the horrible things that
have happened at this ancient castle
like the rat cook who was turned into a
rat by the gods for slaying a guest
under his roof or the 79 sentinels who
deserted the Nights Watch and were
captured and sealed in the ice alive
facing north so that their watch would
never end
he thought of mad acts who prowled the
castle halls barefoot late at night and
murdered his brothers in silence he even
thought of the dreaded thing that came
at night for pretence boys had seen it
all described it differently however but
within one year three of them had died
and the forth boy went insane a century
later this thing came again and
according to the legend all four boys
were seen bound in chains behind it for
all the horror stories of the night form
bran said that one of the scariest was
that of the night's king the night fort
had figured into some of old Nan's
scariest stories it was here that the
night King had reigned before his name
was wiped from the memory of men
the gathering gloom put bran in mind of
another of old Nan's stories the tale of
the night's king he had been the
thirteenth man to lead the Nights Watch
she said a warrior who knew no fear and
that was the fault in him she would add
for all men must know fear a woman was
his downfall
a woman glimpsed from atop the wall with
skin as white as the moon and eyes like
blue stars fearing nothing he chased her
and caught her and loved her though her
kiss was as cold as ice and when he gave
his seed to her he gave his soul as well
he brought her back to the Nightfort and
proclaimed her a queen and himself her
king and with strange sorceries he bound
his sworn brothers to his will for
thirteen years they had ruled nights
king and his corpse queen till finally
the stark of Winterfell and German of
the wild Lynx had joined to free the
watch from bondage after his fall when
it was found that he had been
sacrificing to the others all records of
the Nights King had been destroyed his
very name forbidden some say he was a
Bolton old man who attend some say a
Magna out of scoffs some say Alba Flint
or nori some would have you think he was
a wood foot from them who ruled Bear
Island before the iron men came he never
was he was a stark the brother of the
man who brought him down she always
pitched bran on the nose then he would
never forget it he was a stark of
Winterfell and who can say mayhaps his
name was Brendan mayhaps he slept in
this very room
no brand thought but he walked in this
castle where we'll sleep tonight he did
not like that notion very much at all
night's king was only a man by light of
day old man would always say but the
night was his to rule and it's getting
dark why was his name
wiped from history it says that the
reason was because he sacrificed to the
others but why erase his name if he was
truly a stark then of course the Starks
wouldn't want it widely known since the
Starks ruled the north they better than
anyone could enforce secrecy though the
Starks might have been able to keep the
night Kings real identities secret south
of the wall it would have been
impossible to keep the wildlings who had
also helped take him down from
remembering that he was a start I am
willing to bet that the wildling stories
mentioned the night's king as a stark
what are these strange sorceries
mentioned in my opinion I think he used
skin changing I think that if the
night's king was a stark then he was
probably a powerful skin changer and he
likely skin changed at least some of his
other brothers at least enough to keep
the others in check the fact that he did
this could potentially be part of the
reason skin changing another person is
considered to be such an abomination
beyond the wall again the wildlings
would have not forgotten the truth about
the night's king and who is the night's
queen as a symbol I think she represents
a kind of siren or succubus
he saw her from atop the wall and became
infatuated and when he gave her his seed
she took his soul so that's why I say
she's kind of like a succubus because a
succubus steals a man's soul archetypal
II she is the temptress a woman of
immense provocative charm who utilizes
men and leads them into treacherous
situations
so Georgia Martin says that ice is
revenge ice is cold you inhumanity since
the night Queen is described as cold as
ice and she has blue eyes like the
others I think she likely embodies
Martin's use of the ice archetype I
think that the night's Queen may be a
reference to a specific Jewish
mythological figure and that is Lilith
the first wife of Adam
Lilith refused to be subservient to Adam
she left him and coupled with the
Archangel Sammael and she bore his
offspring and for this God condemned her
and all of her children she became a
demon of the night who would seek her
revenge on the future sons and daughters
of Adam and Eve she was a sexually
wanton woman who stole babies in the
darkness in hebrew lilith translated as
night creatures or night monster or
night hag in the isang of ice and fire
books it says that the night's king and
queen were found to have been
sacrificing to the others but what were
they sacrificing I think the line that
says she took his soul really comes into
play here I think it has two meanings
the first is that he is more bound to
her control than she is to his she is
his queen more than he is her king she
is the true leader here she is very
obviously some sorts of magical being
manipulating the man to her own goals in
some way the second meaning may be more
obvious
he gave her a part of himself his child
I think the night's king and queen must
have been giving their own children to
the others this is the purpose of the
magical where would door in the
Nightfort the door opened its eyes they
were white - and blind
who are you the door asked and the well
whispered who who who I am the sword in
the darkness
samwell tarly said I am The Watcher on
the walls I am the fire that burns
against the cold the light that brings
the dawn the horn that wakes the
sleepers I am the shield that guards the
realms of men
then pass the door said its lips opened
wide and wider and wider still until
nothing remained but a great gaping
mouth in a ring of wrinkles so this door
seems like it can only be opened by a
member of the Nights Watch I think this
was where they took the babies to offer
them to the others otherwise why is this
door in the Nightfort but this door also
seems like the magic of the children of
the forest bran in this chapter remarks
that the face on the door looks like
what a man's face would look like if he
were to live a thousand years that's an
interesting statement considering the
fact that bloodraven has had his life
extended by his tree and is becoming a
part of it and also considering the
other faces with moving eyes that bran
sees in blood Ravens cave that are
ancient and have become a part of the
weirwood is it possible that this face
on the door was once a real person
perhaps even one of the children of the
forest he does after all speak to them
this face however seems to be different
from the others there are no signs
whatsoever of a body and the door has an
odd glow to it a glow came from the wood
like milk and moonlight interestingly
enough the night's Queen is described as
having skin as white as the moon
we don't know how many babies they would
have had but since they ruled for 13
years I would say that 13 babies is a
reasonable number
but why is all of this happening why is
the night's queen doing this it could be
that this was a part of the pact
generations earlier I believe that the
war between mankind and the others
didn't end in one climactic battle but
with a pact made between all of the
present factions these would have
included mankind the children the others
and the Giants though the world of Ice
and Fire mentions that the children and
the Giants were present and helped
during the construction of the wall
there is seemingly no evidence of the
presence of the others or is there the
wall itself is constructed of ice the
others are beings who manipulate ice in
ways that humans cannot even comprehend
their armor and weaponry are all made of
ice their very bodies are physical
manifestations of cold how does an ice
wall stop them I think it is more likely
that they had a hand in its construction
and what of the Horn of Joramun why
would it ever need to exist
except as leverage maintain the pact or
the wall falls I think it is likely in
the novels that the others already do or
soon will possess the Horn of Joramun
the true horn not the false one that
Melisandre burned
maybe the Knights Kings sacrifice of his
children was a part of the pact as well
the weirwood door seems to have been
made with the magic of the children so
they had to have been present at the
time of its construction the magic of
the others cannot cross it which is
demonstrated by the fact that cold hands
cannot go through cold hands is
obviously reanimated by a similar power
to the one that drives the others and if
the door was used to sacrifice to the
others then it is likely that the others
knew of its existence as well
the Starks were present during the long
night
if the night's king was a stark that
means his ancestors were present during
the pact perhaps it was not a mistake
that he saw the night's Queen from atop
the wall and became infatuated perhaps
it was predetermined I used the word
sacrifice but what do we truly know of
what happened to these babies perhaps
the others merely took them into the
land of always winter the children after
all would have been half human and half
whatever the ninth queen was visually
she looks to be a female counterpart of
the male others
interbreeding seems to have been a part
of the initial pact between the children
of the forest on the first min why would
it have not also been a part of the pact
between men and the others even if the
others are descended from the children
as I theorized in the past what they are
now is totally different
they are the physical manifestations of
the cold as I said before they are
living ice what do you get when you
breed that with a human long has there
been hinted to be something special
something important about the stark
bloodline the Starks have to have the
blood of the children of the forest in
my opinion it is why they manifest skin
changing abilities but what would a half
stark half white Walker baby look like
would it look more like a human or more
like one of the others let's say for
instance that if when the king in the
north
and the king-beyond-the-wall brought
down the night's king and his bride they
found a young child a newborn if this
child looked like another they'd likely
kill it but what if it didn't what if
the child looked like a human what if it
looked like a stark
could the king in the north truly slay
his own brother's son I don't think he
would have I think he would have taken
this child and hidden its true identity
perhaps raised him as a stark is it
possible that all of the Starks in our
story
Ned brain Arya John have the blood of
the others and if John is truly the son
of Rhaegar Targaryen this adds even more
weight to him being the Song of Ice and
Fire
magical Targaryen blood and magical
stark blood born in a new resurgence of
magical energy
if the interbreeding of the Starks and
the others was part of the pact and if
it was also part of the pact that the
others got to keep the children that
means that the entire stark line could
be descended from the night's king and
the night's Queen and therefore be
promised to the others a part of a pact
formed by their ancestors thousands of
years ago this doesn't explain however
why the others are just waking up now
why not any other time during the
thousands of years of history since then
the Valyrian Empire rose out of the
shadow of the long night this was during
the time of great magical energy more
Dragons flew the skies in this time than
likely ever before magic seems to have
begun to leave the world after the fall
of the Valyrian Empire currently there
is a very clear resurgence in magical
energy and I think this resurgence may
be a part of some cycle whatever the
reason the others have been waiting for
this new cycle to begin
if the others had came to attack the
realms of men during the time of the
Valyrian Empire would they have stood a
chance against the Valyrians mounted on
their dragons this is questionable
considering how susceptible the white
seemed to be to fire but they also
couldn't come after the fall of the
Empire because they also cannot sway the
flow of the natural world they have to
obey the cycle so they wait for the
resurgence and I believe this is around
the time the comet came given or take a
few decades the others must have known
this time was coming they must have
known what the comment heralded so
they've been preparing preparing to
retake the realms of men
reclaim what is theirs the stark line
perhaps or perhaps there are some other
reason they're choosing to come back in
this way I think it is however heavily
implied that there was a pact that has
been broken and this is the reason that
they are returning this all of course is
just my own theory it's based on
speculation and vague legends in the
deep lore these events happened
thousands of years ago who knows what
truly happened so there you have my
interpretation of the night's king
legend the night's Queen seems to have
been created by the others I think
specifically for the purpose of breeding
with humans how much truth can we take
from these legends how much of it can we
assume actually occurred how much of it
is allegory or symbolic I don't think
it's necessarily meant for us to know
fully
I think it's rather unlikely that we
will ever know definitively the truth
about the night's Queen and the night's
king Georgia Martin is a master of
leaving us questioning what's real and
what's not
I honestly think that Georgia Martin
would make a great horror author I
particularly like the story of the thing
that comes at night that bran recounts
he was scaring himself
there was no thing that comes at night
maester Luwin had said so if there had
ever been such a thing it was gone from
the world now like Giants and Dragons
obviously dragons and Giants do exist
so is George implying that this thing
that comes at night also exists we can
never say for certain the very first
podcast in my playlist deals with some
of the more obscure magical creatures in
A Song of Ice and Fire
George hides them deeply in the lore
this is a world of fantasy and magic so
I don't think it's a stretch to say that
this creature this thing that came in
the night whatever it may have been may
have existed or perhaps still does
somewhere it is very clear that some
legends in Georgia Martin's books depict
real truths and real magic perhaps lost
to time some perhaps not something about
the legend of the night's king and the
night's Queen stands out however there
is truth there we just have to uncover
it I'm not sure if the television shows
version of the night King who is called
the night King and not the night's king
is meant to be the same figure as the
night's king from the books I'm not sure
if that is adding up here I think it's
more likely that they took the name
because it is a good name and tweaked it
slightly showing that it was
distinguished to portray as the head
of the others now Georgia Martin has
said that we will learn more about the
nature of the Wyatt Walker's so maybe in
the winds of winter we'll learn
something about the hierarchy of the
others are there more female White
Walkers like the Nights Queen do they
exist in the land of always winter or
was she specifically made for this
specific purpose and other than that
they don't have females yes I believe
that the others are the remnants of the
children of the forest or at least some
of them that went north and besieged
some power and became these ice beings
but like I said before what they are now
what they became was totally different
from what they were before they were no
longer the children of the forest the
very nature of their existence would
have been altered at this point their
culture would change everything about
them would have changed including
perhaps the way they reproduced perhaps
they could no longer reproduce and a
part of the pact was give us babies and
allow us to continue beyond the wall in
the land of always winter and we will
not attack you the thing is looking at
all of this stuff there is very clearly
some key piece missing some key piece
that is to be revealed and I think the
winds of winter that could tie all of
this together because there is all of
these scattered bits all over the place
all of these hints of all these little
goings-on and you know that they all
must connect in some way but once we
have that key once we unlock it and we
see exactly well maybe not even exactly
but we get a better picture of how all
of these things connect then I feel like
this will come together like some
brilliant tapestry I mentioned Lilith at
the very beginning of this podcast and
if the night's king is in some way a
reference to Lilith then I think it
makes sense that the night's Queen is
kind of this cold ice woman because ice
is revenge and Lilith is revenge
and she sought revenge against all of
the future sons and daughters of Adam
and Eve she preyed upon their children I
also think that it would be kind of a
callback to a Lovecraftian thing if it
turned out that the Starks were
descended from the others because as I
mentioned in the last cast the terrible
ancestry is one of the tropes of
Lovecraft's work that a character has is
descended from some dark and terrible
monstrosity and it usually causes them
anxiety and fear and what's interesting
about that is I think it's so cool that
bran finds the story of the night's king
to be the most terrifying and I think
the reason is because the night's king
was a stark old man tells him that he
was likely a stark and his name might
have even been Brandon so that implies
that he's he's that you're descended for
him that he's related to you in some way
so that is kind of in a way a
Lovecraftian concept if you look at it
the right way I also think that it's
possible that the story of the night's
king in the Nights Queen could be
terribly misrepresented even in old
Nan's story maybe this wasn't a
malicious thing maybe it wasn't that
they were doing some terrible thing in
secret maybe this was in the open the
way warring people have always solve
problems in the assualt of Ice and Fire
world is through marriages they get
married and they join their houses so it
makes sense kind of that the others
would marry into men but maybe it was
Outsiders looking in that saw what was
going on and thought it was so horrible
and then that's what brought them down
they thought it was a big
misunderstanding people with different
views or people that didn't have all the
details just thought
look at him consorting with the others
this is an abomination or whatever and
then it get it gets the story gets
twisted by the victors into this story
of a
and his ice bride that were doing all
this messed up twisted stuff what when
in reality this was a part of a peaceful
pact between men and the others either
way it still remains I think there was a
baby and the theme of the secret baby
being saved and taken somewhere else is
a common theme in A Song of Ice and Fire
this is we see this again and again and
why not think it happened to hear the
legend specifically mentions
specifically the night King giving the
night
Queen his seed why would it say that
except to imply that there was a child
here and like I said they ruled for 13
years so there was likely more than just
one child thanks everyone for listening
it's been great exploring the legend of
the night's king on the night's Queen
it's a lot of fun it's certainly a very
mysterious and spooky legend definitely
the spooky side of a Song of Ice and
Fire is my cup of tea I enjoy that side
of it most of all and like I said George
arm art will make a brilliant horror
writer as always you can follow me on
Twitter for updates on everything and if
you really want to support this channel
you can check me out on patreon I post
stuff up there every month you can
communicate with me there and I'm
getting a live stream started for my $2
an hour patrons I'm gonna be doing a
live stream I'm going to be doing a
patron only live stream every single
month for the $2 patrons and above it's
been fun guys I'll see you on the next
ideas of Ice and Fire cast
I am the last of the Giants my people
are gone from the earth the last of the
great mountain Giants who ruled all the
world at my birth oh the small folk have
stolen my forest they've stolen my
rivers and hills and they've built a
great wall through my valleys and fished
all the fish from my rills in stone
halls they burn their great fires in
stone halls they Forge their sharp
spears whilst I walk alone in the
mountains with no true companion but
tears they hunt me with dogs in the
daylight they hunt me with torches by
night for these men who are small can
never stand tall
while Giants still walk in the light
oh I am the last of the Giants so learn
well the words of my song for when I am
gone the singing will fade and silence
shall last long and long
[Music]